alright alright so if you're wondering
today we are shaving this beautiful head
I'm not prepared at all for this video I
just saw you Honda sitting here in my
makeup chair and was like hey let's
shave your head and for you too
so I actually and it's so random because
guys this is not planned
I brought a pot with me for a whole
other video and now I'm just gonna use
it to shave out it and Johannes ran out
of razors yep so we're gonna use my
razor cuz I wasn't prepared for this
video at all it's new it's a new razor
because mine was very like the blade was
super dull and I was like if we shoot
this we need a good razor so here we go
get the shaving cream oh look at this
actually I'm super excited about this
because now I don't have to do it
I usually shave in the showers that I
use just shampoo no do you have cream
do it girl you know I say yeah we do so
we're using feminine products on you
hotness just don't want to see it oh
this looks awesome
[Laughter]
you must you must you must have so much
fun so first of all it's not a lot of
fun because it takes up a lot of time
like I said I really enjoy this right
now cuz I don't have to do it and it's
always it sounds weird but you know when
somebody I mean no you know cuts your
hair like you PMS gives you a massage
whatever it's always better if someone
else does it so right now this this
feels good we're gonna head massage tape
I swear the best makeup artist always
massage your face before and technically
this is like a part of your face right
yeah a beautiful face needs a lot of
space in a robe on
[Music]
Hey oh yeah you wearing a sports bra
this should be before you start have you
done this before yeah yeah against the
grain yeah that I would do later I would
just go like back first because the hair
grows down so it's like easy to shape
this way a lot of guys tried to do it
like down first but for me I don't know
like this is the long for me right now
like usually I I shave it way before
that stage yeah I know the hardest part
like the top part is easy the hard part
is the back because first of all I don't
see it and there's more hair on the back
like in the top it's where it's receding
so it's it's easier but the back is just
it's annoying because you have the bones
out of your skull so it's like a little
but at least I have that I don't know if
everybody I'm appreciate everybody else
else you know right like these she's
right here okay jave around them is
pretty tough especially with no eyes oh
no I know I don't want to do that I'm
British it within the next couple of
years it will lose all of my hair and
then I don't have to see
Oh No just rock it look at this I have a
beautiful girl
woman right next to me shaving my head I
need some hair in my face exactly do you
know check since you answer your
questions to people or guys be
embarrassed about
you know people that's a super common
thing and we know like I share this with
you all the time because I get a lot of
DMS from guys and I try to respond to
every single one of them when they start
losing their hair they get I don't want
to say insecure but like I think that's
that's the word right
like just insecure like they lose their
self-confidence and then they wear hats
they wear hats all the time I mean I
like wearing hats too but not because
I'm ashamed of of not having hair just
like it but yeah some guys do that to
cover up you know not having hair but
there's absolutely no need for that it's
just hair it has nothing to do with your
personality it has nothing to do it's
cool maybe times or you know actually
some other guys want to know what other
guys think - yeah
so it's good
but what I will say is I think it's
you're actually the only and that
performed very well but the acting was
really good question how low do I go for
the sideburns oh you go you can go like
where my ears I don't see it so I'll
just hear if that's what you want to
shape you you know how that the barbers
like have those fine razors but we don't
have that yep guys if you know of any
good racers like that comment below so I
can start like I know they're super
dangerous uh-huh cuz they're so sharp
but the barbershop Jeff's barbershop
when did you decide to commit yeah I
don't have the answer do you know when
it was
I remember where it was it was a 1,600
three years ago I remember it was in
that tiny little room with a security
guard yelled at us just like there's no
filming in here sony 4k whatever
cyber-shot what was the camera like
super tiny yeah and he was like you're
not allowed to film in here when I went
to the military military service in
Austria I did it too
ya see the strong military men to do it
so if anybody out there is experiencing
hair loss or whatever and you decide to
shave your head everything the first
weeks gonna feel and look just
everything's gonna be super weird cuz
you will feel the wind on your head and
around your ears because you don't have
any hair anymore and just looking in the
mirror it's gonna be like whoa that's
weird
or taking a shower is interesting
because you want to go through your hair
but it's not there anymore so all of
that was like the first week or like the
first two weeks was there's so many
experiences so many like not emotions
which is like feelings it was awesome
and then I loved it you know what I mean
so many it was it was cool because it's
like it's new it's like a new haircut it
I mean I know it's no hair but like I
think it's but it's it's considered a
haircut trust me with my store give me a
break I posted on YouTube and forever
and now you guys your comments asking me
to and asking me for different videos is
super motivating so thank you
now I'm posting again okay how about a
hundred thousand views yeah fifteen
thousand comments no fifty thousand
let's start one hundred thousand views
on what time frame in a week No so let's
you let's zoom five hundred thousand
views in a week service once a week deal
nice guys make sure make sure to share
this video with all of your friends post
it everywhere you can don't I'm hoping
for no views on this video time time is
money that's also why I'm like doing
these types of videos for you guys too
because they're super like fun and easy
to do and also like with everything else
going on what makes this I can be
consistent and actually doing the things
that I really do everyday life like
Johannes had to shave set this happens
like I hope you want to sell it with the
back of his head a lot yeah I don't know
what's going on here
oh oh that's already shaved spoliation
oh my gosh this must be great
exfoliation all right I'm gonna finish
this baby off of us to machine I do want
you to
there we go hello mr. white so I'm doing
the neck now and then get those
stragglers over here get yourself a girl
that I'll shave your head good yeah yeah
the first time I shaved your Hamas's
head was for an Instagram skit he told
me to buzz it right off but little did I
know he wanted to shave it anyway
I like that though I like accepting I'm
losing my hair and instead of trying to
hide it
it's just shaving it off confidence and
a man is like one of the sexiest things
not like cocky don't confuse it just
like confident good and secure with
himself behind the ear and make sure you
clean behind your ears guys a lot of
guys don't it's gross
I discovered that I was checking behind
all these guys I'm like me see 300 years
95% was unbelievable 30 years I'm gonna
put some oil on after - mmm walrus watch
what if that's not a nice looking head I
don't know what is
beautiful now that is a sexy man with
the sexy bald head and I love it thank
you guys for watching you can do it we
need some beard oil too
oh I have for you do you wanna do this
sign up yes thank you so much for
watching guys don't forget to hit the
notification button up there leave a
comment and like let im gonna know what
you want to see next if you want to see
oh and don't forget share this with
video with everybody we need five
hundred thousand views and I can get my
head shaven every week
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]